my name is Missoula and I am 20 years  old I was born in Chavez in Portugal I  have lived in Paris for 15 years I'm  Franco Portuguese and of course  supporting Portugal at the euros I think  we can make the final Portugal has a  good team above all Cristiano Ronaldo he  has always been successful he is the  best  that's Cristiano for us he is the player  there are many Portuguese here we like  partying together singing the songs at  the fanzone is great our country our  roots  Portugal's history that's all in the  songs it's important for us to sing them  before a match  all the Portuguese are here a big family  we're going to celebrate  let's go Portugal Thanks